englisch was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video jahr
wollte ich natürlich gut
es ist ein format was ich vor genau
einem jahr gestartet hat oder ist es
schon länger her
vor eineinhalb jahren habe ich das
gestartet was nicht praktisch verfolgt
rund ums jahr verteilt kriege ich fast
täglich nachrichten allerdings kannst
mal ein bisschen wieder auf zeugnisse
reagieren und ich habe ja schon wirklich
oft gesagt hey leute es reicht jetzt
einfach mal oder ich hab mir in meinem
leben jetzt bestimmt schon 300
verschiedene zeugnisse gefühlt
angeschaut und irgendwann gibt es halt
auch nichts mehr was mich umhauen kann
trotzdem habe ich mich jetzt praktisch
dazu überreden lassen das noch mal zu
machen aus folgendem grund weil es heute
in nrw wo ich wurde zeugnisse gehabt und
mir ganz viele geschrieben haben auch
automatisch erzeugt uns geschickt haben
und ja gefühlt ganz deutschland
schulferien hat und auch schon seit
längerer zeit ferien und ich habe viele
zeugnisse bekommen
ich habe euch nochmal auf instagram
aufgefordert mir zeugnisse zu schicken
und ich habe mir ein paar rausgesucht
die meiner meinung nach die
interessantesten sind und ja die schauen
uns heute an erstmal vorweg noch ich
hoffe ihr hattet alle ein cooles
schuljahr und seid ihr zufrieden mit
ihrem zeugnis
ich bin froh dass ich kein zeugnis mehr
bekommen werde in meinem leben und let's
go fangen wir mal mit dem ersten an und
zwar kommt das von ich hoffe ich spreche
dann haben richtig aus oder sagt der hat
mir nämlich über instagram das zeugnis
geschickt und dazu geschrieben
ich bin erst drei jahre in deutschland
das heißt er lebt er seit drei jahren
vermutlich in deutschland ja was auch
sonst
und hat somit auch erst seit drei jahren
die chance wirklich deutsch zu lernen
was jetzt noch keine katze lange zeit
ist trotzdem ist es ja bei kindern so
dass die sich schneller ansprachen
gewinn und auch schneller
diese sprachen erlernen können und vor
allem wenn man dann auch voll geballert
wird mit deutschen mitschülern die nur
deutschland
deswegen bin ich jetzt mal gespannt was
er vom zeugnis hat und ich muss sagen
das sieht gar nicht mal so schlecht aus
also ich bin begeistert das finde ich
richtig gut und das freut mich auch er
geht auf der realschule also ich sag mal
so die zweitbeste schulform gymnasium
realschule hauptschule dass wir da so
unterteilt und fährt dann ist ja völlig
in ordnung und dann auch noch mit 0 3 an
deutschkenntnissen ja okay für
uns und textilgestaltung und sport
braucht man auch keinen deut darum
ehrlich zu sein wer schafft mit drei
jahren deutsch kennen ist schon so ein
gutes zeugnis wir haben in deutsch 204
aber das ist ja auch ausreichend sagt ja
der name schon und den rest muss ich
euch auch irgendwie gar nicht vorlesen
kann es ja selber sehen also mach weiter
so wenn du das hat mich sehr gefreut
dass ich mir jetzt geschickt hast und
ich hoffe du machst einen
realschulabschluss oder schauen wir mal
wie es weitergeht schreibt mir dann
gerne mal interessiert mich auf jeden
fall machen arbeiter mit diesem zeugnis
das kommt ich glaube ich hatte in der
ganzen zeit in jedem format hatte ich
nicht einen grundschulzeugnis drin und
das habe ich damit begründet ja gut also
welcher grundschüler ist auch schon so
wirklich in der lage mir sein zeugnis
über ins all zu schicken nur wir leben
ja im jahr 2019 und da ist das natürlich
gar kein problem
dieses mal habe ich wirklich viele
zeugnisse aus grundschulen bekommen und
hier hat mich eins vor allem überzeugt
und zwar ich weiß nicht die qualität ist
nicht so nice aber teilnahme an
folgenden arbeitsgemeinschaften
fördermaßnahmen elias hat an der
arbeitsgemeinschaft blockflöte
teilgenommen blockflöte war für mich
immer das sorry an die die jetzt
blockflöte spiel und auch elias wenn ihr
das spaß macht war jetzt weg ich finde
das ist wirklich das langweiligste
instrument das es gibt also wenn ich
mich daran zurück erinnere wie früher
auch so ein paar freunde und freunde von
mir in so einem blockflöten blockflöte
den song blockflöten kurs waren war das
ist ja ab
und dann noch diese schiefen töne ja
manchmal rauskommen da kann ich durch
tragen bei diesen geräuschen
aber elias ob das jetzt richtig war das
so anzusprechen ich meine ich glaube so
grundschüler die kann man damit schon
die sie beeinflussen nachher sagte er zu
seiner lehrerin frau müller
der alex hat gesagt blockflöte ist
absolut scheiße und dann später das
nächste mal an der arbeitsgemeinschaft
blockflöte mit wenigem erfolg
teilgenommen und dann ist die mutter von
elias dauer nur wegen mir okay wir
machen weiter und zwar kommen wir jetzt
zu einem zeugnis von einem sehr guten
freund von mir
falls das siehst du siehst ja bestimmt
schöne grüße ich kenne sie auf den namen
extra und der hat mir das geschickt und
meinte hier guck mal einmal vorher und
nachher also erstes halbjahr ein zweites
halbjahr oder halt wie er sich
gesteigert hat
aber ich zeige euch jemand das erste
halbjahr wir haben erst mal 345 versäumt
vier stunden das ist schon also ist es
das zweithöchste was ich je in der
ganzen staffel
ich reagiere auf eure zeugnisse gesehen
habt das heftigste war 628 aber das lag
halt an einer krankheit die wahrheit so
gut wie gar nicht da und er war jetzt
ich weiß was ja nicht sonderlich krank
dann wird auch irgendwann die
testpflicht eingeführt auf jeden fall
oder von auch noch 790 und ein schild ja
gut an sich außerdem ausreichend
ausreichend ausreichend und so weiter
und dann switch vorüber und dann haben
wir hier das abschlusszeugnis und das
ist enorm nach oben gegangen
schaut mal als wir haben noch 344 ok
sport sehr gut politik sehr gut was sich
da jetzt eigentlich so viel verbessert
ja also die politik note auf jeden fall
und sonst so ein bisschen nach oben
gegangen ist es macht meine so ich bin
mächtig stolz auf dich okay
kommen wir zum lukas klasse 12b ich
glaube das ist wahrscheinlich österreich
oder so weil 12b und realschule das
gibts doch in deutschland gar nicht also
realschule geht ja nur bis zu zehn
zumindest lege ich da jetzt falsch
korrigiert mich in den kommentaren und
lukas hat mir das hier zugeschickt das
ist gar kein zeugnis sondern ein
leistungsnachweis oder eine leistungs
bescheinigung dann ist jetzt mal und
zwar weil lukas jahrgangsstufen bester
mit einem notendurchschnitt von 1,4 als
an euch alle ihr werdet so was er in der
hand halten so kann es aber aussehen
okay das war jetzt bisschen gemein ich
war auch nie gut also was heißt nicht
gut schlag für bei 2,4 250 lukas an dich
1,4 ist natürlich ein super schnitt aber
wenn ich mich an meine stufe zurück
erinnere werten gleich drei die hatten
1,0
also musste noch ein bisschen dass ihr
wollt dialog mit rein nehmen und zwar
ist das ein zeugnis der neuen
mittelschule und da habe ich meine frage
du willst auf die neue mittelschule und
wieso steht dann hinter jeder note
allgemeine sonderschule weil in
deutschland ist sonderschule also jetzt
nichts gegen leute die auf eine
sonderschule gehen aber ist eine
sonderschule für leute die besonders
gefördert werden müssen
warum steht dass da schreibt mir das
selbst gerne in die kommentare
wir haben da noch ein letztes und zwar
ist das irgendwie so ein ganz special
ding von einer montessori schule habe
ich in meinem leben noch nie gehört
keine ahnung was es ist aber wenn ihr
euch mal die noten anschaut
irgendwie werde ich darüber mit schleier
aus + + + kreuz und die fächer sind halt
wirklich komplett anders
selbstständigkeit motivation
konzentration sorgfalt sozial falten
also mathe und so haben die gar nicht da
fehlt ja irgendwie alles ist also das ja
eine ganz andere richtung von fächern
muss ich aber wirklich sagen für mich
gar nicht mal so schlecht also sofern
man in dem fach selbstständigkeit zum
beispiel lernt mit steuern umzugehen wie
man sich eine wohnung sucht motivation
wie man sich für das ganze motiviert
sorgfalt wie man mit dokumenten
umzugehen hat usw
also wenn diese sachen thematisiert
werden was ich jetzt nicht weiß dann ist
das mehr gutes konzept und das ganze
andere deutsche schulsystem kannst du
den kopf getreten weil das ist für mich
wirklich habe ich ja schon sehr oft mal
was du gesagt ich bin sehr froh dass ich
mein abitur in der tasche haben und bin
auch froh dass ich nie wieder wirklich
lernen muss für die schule
es war eine super zeit mit sehr vielen
freunden und so aber dieser lernstoff
immer gegen acht davon brauche ich gar
nicht wirklich wenn ich jetzt an meinem
beruf denkt und mein studium von dem was
sie in der schule gelernt habe gut
rechnen zu können ein bisschen politik
drauf zu haben
auch geschichte mal gehabt zu haben ist
gut aber das meiste kompletter müll
meiner meinung nach das war's haut rein
wir sehen uns dann in einem halben jahr
beim nächsten ich reagiere auf eure
zeugnisse